it's common knowledge that raising too
much money before you launch can be
extremely dangerous
quibby is a great example of what can
happen when you delay launching a
product to real users for years
and then find out that no one wants what
you're building but what if i told you
that there was a company with over five
times as much funding as quibby that has
yet to launch a commercial product
as crazy as the idea of pouring 10
billion dollars into an idea before
launching it is
it's actually happening and it might not
be as crazy as you think
i'm john coogan and today i want to talk
about the self-driving car company waymo
founded in 2009 by google waymo has had
its sights set on developing a fully
autonomous vehicle for the past decade
and they've made some really incredible
progress but the fact that they have yet
to get a fully
self-driving car in the hands of
consumers raises some interesting
questions
about the best practices we often assume
to be true about startups
is it okay to spend billions of dollars
on research and development before
launching
or do you always need to be
incorporating feedback from real
customers
in order to validate your idea from the
earliest possible moment
let's start with a little history
sebastian throne and anthony lewandowski
started waymo
as an internal project at google most of
the early team members had been part of
the 2005 darpa grand challenge
where they competed to race fully
autonomous vehicles through a
complicated course of obstacles and
unpredictable terrain
after six years in what was essentially
fully stealth development
google spun off the project as its own
division under the alphabet umbrella
and renamed the company waymo a nod to
its mission of creating
a new way forward in mobility it's now
been over 10 years since the project
started
and the company has evolved
significantly waymo has driven over 20
million miles on real-world
roads yielding tons of data they use to
train their autonomous driving models
they have also released five iterations
of their self-driving vehicles
each with improvements to the core
self-driving systems
and perhaps most significant to our
discussion today this year they raised
outside funding for the first time
by raising three billion dollars at a 30
billion dollar valuation
wemo ensured that they have the funds to
continue to develop the technology
and potentially set themselves up to one
day be fully independent from google
but despite all of these milestones
waymo has yet to launch a consumer
product that actually delivers a rider
to their destination
without the involvement of a human being
to be fair they did just recently launch
waymo 1
which allows users of their app to hail
an autonomous waymo vehicle
in the phoenix area but each waymo
vehicle still has a human safety driver
at the wheel
ready to take over if the autonomous
systems fail now
i don't want to be unfair to weymouth
since they have clearly accomplished
something remarkable
but it remains to be seen if this is a
true violation of the axiom that you
should always launch early
the crux of this debate revolves around
the market for fully self-driving cars
in order to understand what that market
might look like in the future
we need to talk about the different
levels of autonomy the society of
automotive engineers has divided
self-driving capabilities into six
levels
level one autonomy includes basic
assistance features such as adaptive
cruise control
but level two is where it really starts
to get interesting at level two the car
should be able to adjust both
acceleration
and steering but it still requires a
human driver to be alert and ready to
take over if the system can't handle a
current situation
this is where most of the commercially
available autonomy systems sit currently
tesla's autopilot and gm's supercrews
are both level 2 systems that have
received amazing reviews from users
level 3 is similar to level 2 but it
does not require the driver to monitor
the environment
but waymo is going beyond this jumping
directly to level 4 autonomy
where the vehicle performs all driving
functions under certain conditions
while other companies have iterated
through the lower levels in order to
improve their systems
waymo has targeted level 4 self-driving
from the beginning
and while level 4 sounds amazing on
paper there are some serious drawbacks
to consider
first is what sets it apart from level
5.
at level 5 the vehicle is capable of
performing all driving functions under
all conditions but waymo isn't there yet
the system works great on the wide open
and typically dry roads of phoenix
arizona
but driving on the icy and congested
roads of boston
is still a long way off driving on clean
roads in good weather
looks like a solved problem at this
point but in messy conditions with
aggressive drivers
the problem starts to look a lot more
like game theory than pathfinding
the second major issue waymo is facing
is the speed of their vehicles
although the vehicle can reliably go the
speed limit safety is the first priority
in these systems
so the cars tend to yield more often
than a human driver would
most people tend to bend the rules a bit
when they are driving rolling the
occasional stop sign
and cutting someone off to get ahead in
a traffic jam these little shortcuts do
wind up saving time
but they come with the additional risk
of a crash when you're at the wheel
you can make the decision to trade
safety for speed based on your own risk
tolerance
but when you're in a waymo you only have
one option full safety
and this could be a real problem for
waymo let's assume that waymo's vehicles
are as safe
if not safer than taking an uber or lift
but are slightly slower
due to the less aggressive driving style
even if waymo can reduce the cost of a
trip
by removing the human driver will
customers be willing to trade speed
for this cost savings fortunately we do
have some data that can help us answer
this question
uber has started a ride sharing offering
called uberpool
which is cheaper but slower than a
direct trip since you're sharing the car
with someone else
despite these rides being cheaper only
20 of uber's customers select the
uberpool feature
the market for robo-taxis that are
cheaper but slower
might be significantly smaller than the
overall ride sharing market
taking these two issues together paints
a bit of a risky picture
waymo may only be able to operate in
uncongested cities
during good weather conditions and even
then many customers may still
opt to pay a premium to be driven by an
aggressive human driver who can get them
to their destination quicker
now to be fair both of these issues can
be solved by improving the core
autonomous systems
and we might eventually see fully
autonomous robo taxis tearing through
the streets of boston during a snowstorm
safely at 40 miles per hour but that
feels a long way off
and the question of how we get there is
still an open one even though waymo has
amassed 20 million miles of driving data
tesla recently hit over 3 billion miles
driven with the autopilot system engaged
it still remains to be seen which
approach will deliver a full featured
and profitable level 4 autonomous
vehicle business
the conventional wisdom of the tech
industry would suggest that iterating
directly with real world customers
like what tesla is doing would be
superior to the waymo model
but only time will tell i personally
hope waymo winds up working
10 billion dollars in pre-launch funding
creates some pretty huge shoes to fill
but if anyone can stick to landing on a
project like this it's the team at waymo
i'd like to hear from you though who do
you think will win in the battle to
produce a fully autonomous vehicle
that can be widely used by consumers let
me know in the comments if you think
waymo
tesla or another company entirely has
the best shot
and if you enjoyed this video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching